what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on pump to be
talking about black corporate America we
have dual love joining us on the show hi
Joe
hey thanks for coming on the program
yeah glad to be here looking forward to
this likewise I'm super comfy grateful
to John Schiller for introducing us
absolutely yeah yeah those who don't
know drools background he's CEO at black
executive men in Champions mental health
helping black men and women in corporate
America find inner peace and positive
mental health he's also the founder of
urban healers which initiates urban men
into healthy manhood by harnessing alpha
energy for pro-social outcomes you can
find black executive men calm also the
urban healers dot-com links in the bye
below as well as the YouTube channel
where jewels now starting to post lots
of really good content check that out
and also has LinkedIn Instagram profiles
absolutely alright what start things off
with some of our favorite questions we
like asking our guests we've been so
fascinated with the nature of reality
what do you think is the nature of this
reality yeah so I was thinking about
that a bit and when I think about
reality I think about kind of breaking
it down to what's real and I think about
what's real I think about perception and
there's multiple levels of perception
there's just kind of waking walking
world where things seem to be you know
pretty tangible and tactile for the most
part but then you have other realms such
as the dream realm where you know
there's a lot of movement it's not fully
clear Wow real that is but to the senses
kind of like in the VR world it can feel
very real so what comes to mind is that
there are actually different levels of
reality and perception that's happening
there I mean there's even things that we
can't hear or smell that dogs in this
world are very keen of so when we talk
about the
about reality I think it's just there's
a lot of levels of reality all happening
at the same time and it may also be a
question about perception what can we
see on these different realms that are
happening my guess and you know kind of
what we're learning and it's like a eye
and like superhuman intelligence and
things like that is there's going to be
ways of seeing things and even
processing energy or excuse me
processing information that we don't
even have access to yet so when I think
about reality nature reality I think
right now for most of us it's limited to
what we can currently see and then we
make you know assumptions or deductions
based on that but we're really limited
on what we can even you know witness
with the faculties that we have and how
much they're developed or underdeveloped
etc so from that point I think of okay
well that's the case then who may have
some kind of like greater perception
that links into some deeper or
all-knowing reality and of course well
not of course but my mind goes to
Eastern traditions and you know yogic
practices and certain meditations and
philosophies and practices leading
toward or around and lighten mint you
know and people giving reports of being
connected to something much greater so
like the mind goes to like God or some
all-knowing force or being or state of
consciousness or awareness so I think
that's another perception of another
plane
connecting to a reality that exists
there and may permeate many or all of
these other realities I haven't
experienced that so I can't speak to
that but those are the things that come
to mind so all that context to say that
I'm limited on what I can even perceive
the overall reality to be even if that's
a relevant question on certain levels of
perception around reality
but from this world what reality seems
to be to me now in this walking waking
world is something around I'd say this
interaction between thoughts will in
tension and this connection between this
inner world and outer world and there's
actually a play happening where things
on our inner plane can be manifested on
this slower material world and there's
things beyond just what we think and
what we believe like the nature around
us which seems to just go which just
goes on its own so what comes to mind is
relationships the nature of this reality
it's relationships between many
different beings and entities you know
life transitions and death and rebirth I
think that cycle is is the nature of
reality as far as I can perceive it yes
yeah do you feel like we are all one you
know I don't I don't it's in it's an
interesting question because there's a
level in which you know molecular Li you
know we're all they're all all these
molecules are engaging and interacting
with each others and no true kind of
like it's all relational as opposed to
being some full-on separation there's
always that and we have that right
there's like from what I can perceive
believe there's a separation between us
and these visible beings and entities
and these bodies if you will but there
are like sub molecular or molecular
aspects to us which you know do connect
and then there's the spiritual realm and
there's deeper realms of spirituality
where one could say we're all one and I
think it's a it's it's a matter of
perception I think in this here reality
no we're not one we're two or maybe more
I don't you know but two is what comes
to mind but I think on some other levels
of perception absolutely I mean I heard
a metaphor that said you know it's like
there's a hand and the fingers believe
that they're all individual but they're
connected to the same hand and connected
to the same body yes so truly like the
breath of life yeah absolutely whatever
is breathing into us to animate us I'm
sure it's coming from I imagine it's
coming from the same source in the same
place so it's it's a yes and a no and I
think it depends on the question of what
realm are we speaking of and what do you
think is the most upstream issue that we
face as a society yeah and I love to
quantify our qualify when we say a
society are we talking about the United
States of America okay so the whole
earth like all people on earth right now
yeah it's interesting because I fit okay
no issue that we're facing most upstream
most blood stream route issue you know
earlier you're talking about this yeah
yeah right the cycle of the inhales that
I take income from phytoplankton and
trees and the bite of food that I take
of an apple comes from the power of the
Sun the depth of interconnectedness is
so visible scientifically and
spiritually through everything that it
takes our lens to be augmented or our
perspective to be augmented to get to
that degree so sometimes it makes me
feel like the most route or the most
upstream issue is our lack of perceiving
the interconnectedness as the truth and
our feelings of separation and you
actually write that to that it's the
biggest issue is our feelings of
separation yeah so definitely wrote that
in webpage for urban healers and that's
I think it's very true in many in many
ways especially when the realm of
psychotherapy people feeling
disconnected from the world around them
their their family many times or even
from their set themselves
mainly but answer your question I think
it has to do with most upstream might be
somewhat middle of stream as well in
some cases downstream depending on the
part of the world you're living in is
humanities acceleration as far as
population and our relationship to the
earth as far as resource management yeah
and the decisions that we're making in
order to be in harmony and in alignment
with this planet I mean we're seeing
population growth from the studies you
know been around 37 years but from what
I can tell we're exploding is a
population and just being mindful of how
we use resources on this finit amount of
land and water that we have to utilize
for now I mean there's you know movement
to other planets etc but that's not here
yet so I think there's just something
real about here we have this one planet
population growth is significant and how
we're using the land and the resources
on it to make sure that we can sustain
this you know for ever like how do we do
that I think that's significant yeah yes
yeah that's a very good upstream issue
and then it speaks really deeply to the
interconnectedness the more symbiotic we
are with our environment with nature and
what sustains us given our population
and given our desire to extract more of
the natural resources from the planet in
order to make the technology and in
order to power our energy uses mm-hm is
gonna need to be yeah recalibrated to a
more harmonious degree in order for us
to to actually actually prosper more
synergistically does yeah great
what does it feel like the purpose of
creation it is yeah the purpose of
creation
the word that comes to mind is value to
create some value the thing is it might
not always be a positive or feel-good
value
you know diseases are created in some
way shape or form and then they're here
and then cancer and it kills people and
so the people don't find a whole lot of
value or as far as feel-good value in it
but it does serve a well I guess that
just goes back to purpose but something
in value I mean then I can take it more
personally right there's just various
ways to answer but personally when I'm
involved in creating black executive men
or healers or interracial couples
counseling or whatever the brand it is
that I've created or I am creating
there's an interest to identify a need
that people have our pain point that
people have or a sense of disconnection
that people are experiencing and then
providing a space in a world really for
people to truly feel seen for their
identity or internal reality that makes
sense in the larger society so that they
can feel like they fit in to that zone
and they have a home but even connected
to the greater society that we have
going on which is why I say value I want
to create something that adds value and
meaning to people's lives and ideally a
sense of belonging yes yeah regarding
the creation providing the value of this
reality where we can endeavor into
consciousness and experience the
illusion of separation where we
ourselves can brings forth some sort of
gifts and value into the world that
transcend us does it feel like modernity
is missing some sort of more primordial
indigenous principles around
interconnectedness symbiosis with the
environment
deep love with one another does it feel
like those principles are missing from
modernity in this grand time trajectory
that we've had where 0.1 percent of its
been in the industrial revolution and
enlightenment era another 99.9 percent
has been since the beginning of humans
through the agrarian times until now
does it feel like we're overly hubristic
in modernity overly self-confident
hmm overly self-confident and are
missing some of those principles yeah
yeah overly self-confident doesn't
necessarily come to mind for me but
missing some of those principles I'd say
definitely I mean it just people are
feeling isolated many people alone in
the world
disconnected through the hyper
individuals individualism that we have
and that's promoted and that's very much
valued and that's driving a lot of the
innovation I mean we're we're off the
grid man we don't have to abide
necessarily to this tribes tradition
where you worship the elders and what
they say goes and your place in your
your your your you know sibling line
determines kind of your obedience it's
like people broke free they can do what
they want and there's beauty in that
there's a freedom and there's an
explosion hence this America that we
have here you know connected with this
values of like freedom of speech and
thought even an action to a degree that
and a lot of other cultures just don't
it's just not you just can't do that
because your very identity is a group
identity and it's so locked in so I
think yes there are some things that we
are definitely missing that a being that
really group tie that a lot of people
I'd say probably indigenous people
they're like I Know Who I am
like I'm these people like not even just
a person this is my people I am we I am
we kind of a thing and there's a level
of peace with that that they have that a
lot of people struggle with in the West
because it's so much about finding out
the eye and asserting the eye many times
not all the times and impacting
in that way yes oh I see I see a missing
definitely yeah I definitely see some
missing pieces and then it's you know
incumbent on us to kind of on those who
want to to kind of look back or recreate
anew communities that are deeply
meaningful for them for them here in
this in this culture and that's
definitely something that I've done and
made a point to do and feel grateful
really grateful to have done and be
doing yeah does it feel like the
creation is perfect there's a perfect
harmonization of good and evil forces
that are pressed up against one each
other pressure cooking evolution yeah
got it so perfect
I would say this is a funny this is the
funny point I love this kind of question
yeah yep I would say so
this one's saying life is pretty damn
good right now that's what I'll say it's
feeling really good and in and I hold
the perspective of really being able to
work with the situation that life tosses
me or you or anybody and having an
opportunity to work it out and that so
much meaning can be created even in the
evil or will necessarily use that term
but just hard times that come by are
things that are deeply confusing and
folks don't have that or I may not have
the answer to it's truly this
opportunity to figure it out and learn
how to surf that wave in order to find
alignment with it and peace inside or
meaning inside with it now that's very
you know personal it's just my
perspective now it's hard for me to
exactly say worldview as far as the rest
of the world but for me dual love yeah
yeah I could see it being perfect as in
there's an opportunity for creation
there's always an opportunity for
creation and meaning making in it so I
guess I'm flipping a little bit
perfection into opportunity to create
meaning yeah yeah yeah that same
opportunity that you talked about to me
is so deeply about that that pressure
cooker that's happening that enables the
spiritual path to be explored and so the
opportunity is there for it to happen
of always yeah this is if it was
lopsided in one of those directions
there may not be but because it's so it
seems perfect that there is that
opportunity for paths of awakening
absolutely yeah
do you see your childhood being born in
Oakland and raised here huh do you see
that and what you experienced growing up
and how you got interested in black
studies and went to major in that at UC
Santa Barbara do you feel like that was
influenced by your lineage and like
going all the way back to like the
traumas of the transatlantic slave trade
and how that's affecting our the United
States and even the rest of the world do
you feel like that's deeply affected and
also on the process of healing do you
feel like the work you're doing now is a
big part of the society-wide desire to
heal mm-hmm yeah I do I feel like it's
definitely connected to larger societies
movement toward you know wanting to heal
you know a lot of personal a lot of
personal wounds that people have many
times that are put together with a lot
of historical traumas which there's none
of that there and the beauty of
something like psychotherapy and getting
back to my childhood and how it connects
to psychotherapy in a moment is that
when people come into psychotherapy and
how it's definitely connected to the
West and a beautiful offering from the
West is it actually takes into account
people's larger lineage stories you know
but it doesn't stop there it actually
gets into people's personal story so I
know for myself when I was in mid-20s
went on this whole spiritual journey and
really mainly reading a little bit of
traveling but mainly reading about
Hinduism and Christianity and Judaism
and
Selam and you know just kind of took it
took a walk around the block everything
saw what there was to see a lot of
amazing teachings none of them my own
none of them my own it was about many
other people's stories none of them my
own and so when I stumbled on
psychotherapy it was about going into my
own story and the therapist I had at the
time was really big on dream work so
when I talk about different realities
and dreams and that was a whole nother
reality which just opened up this
intelligence to things I had never had
experienced but some part of me was
living it and it was very very real and
it helped me not only tap into what my
lived lived lived story had been in this
body but a living into other narratives
on other planes that became very very
real for me and so my own narrative
started blossoming really and I found
that to just be a beautiful gift it was
just mind opening and wasn't limited to
this realm but it was very much coming
from inside of me so it's just
empowering kind of personal relationship
so for me when I think of healing this
is my primary modality in psychotherapy
and I think it's a beautiful connection
to all of our lineages and people that
are Jewish or black or Scottish or that
but then there's something uniquely your
own and giving people the opportunity to
really be with and cultivate and know
and explore this endless place inside of
them and have that kind of relationship
that's actually beyond their skin or
their gender or sexual orientation etc
etc I think there's a level of freedom
in that experience and so yes I
definitely work with black corporate
America but even in that work it goes
into some realms that are highly
personal which do relate to race but
also relate to things that are not
necessarily based about race but pull
from other narratives and realms that
come from within
individual as well yeah so put that out
there around healing and then my
relationship like to it and how I find
value in relationship to it is having
that experience with people because I
get to go on the journey too and that's
fun for me connect yeah yeah yeah so yes
to society but also yes to duel love
like yes to what I get to experience
with people yeah in that that
relationship it's a unique relationship
yeah it's a very personal relationship
deeply intimate yes but also 50 minutes
and it's by you know a very unique
relationship and I don't see them again
until the next time they come in I may
not even think about them till the next
time they come in so unique it is it's
so beautiful would you call it a an
ascension that you get to go on with the
different you know when I that's an
interesting word I like that I like that
because there's like an you know an
elevated yeah ninis to it but it's not
always in and a blast off right
sometimes it's a deep dive sometimes we
just cry together yes yes and I'm not
crying I'm not sad about anything in my
life at that moment but yeah because of
what they're bringing in I get to go
there in me and tap that place in me and
be there with them so I think for me you
know psyche root word soul is what it
feels like for me it's whatever the
realm of the soul is it feels like I get
to hold space and open that up and be
with people on the realm of the soul
wherever that goes I love joyful places
deeply painful places deeply angry
places deeply wounded places and get to
be with people in those places and
because our society this Western world
maybe that's the difference from some of
these tribal or indigenous communities
where they have rituals that people can
bring in sadness or grief in the
community would process
that with them and in the West we don't
form any of these things somebody has a
a miscarriage they may tell their
homegirl and keep it pushing and hold it
deep inside of them about how
traumatizing or painful it is until they
bone they're in with a therapist and now
they have somebody who can hold them
energetically and psychologically to to
process that experience and so
therapists kind of hold that indigenous
in a way this realm of the soul kind of
holder in the modern era and we dress
like this but in reality we may play a
role similar not the same but is maybe
like a shaman or an indigenous healer in
another tradition or culture Wow yeah I
mean I'm sure you know that you know
that Harrison though I'm sure you've
heard that I don't think people make the
jump from it's really interesting
comparison it's a great comparison
between the indigenous shamanic or
tribal healers that that no plan
medicines and that know the depths of
the psyche em the interconnectedness of
that web of life and then versus in
modernity where you have
psychotherapists that hold space for
what feels like many times people that
are that are feeling very unfit in the
economic machinery in some way or in
their familial machinery in some way in
that psychotherapists do hold that space
they hold that space for the depths of
the psyche as well yet there is a
proclivity to prescribe like
pharmaceuticals rather than leverage
like plant medicine yes and leverage
could be changing you know yeah this is
exciting too holistic is bringing that
west and that East yeah south and south
and north yeah we just in the last
episode this and we were talking about
that exact saw that it's just
yeah yeah the south the north come
together to with the east and west night
yeah exactly
I like that jump I think it's a really
good jump I think it's also important to
express how you you you know how you're
putting it which is that holding space
from the heart to help that person go on
their path their their spiritual journey
that there's some sort of an ascension
there's some sort of an evolution some
sort of a process of growth that happens
that you get to be there with them that
you get to yeah reduce if I love it
that's why that's why I do it you know
this is crazy cuz when when someone like
you know you're young by the time you're
in your later parts of your life you're
gonna have seen tens of thousands of
people you're gonna know the ins and
outs of the psyche and and that's gonna
that's a real privilege and you have a
big responsibility to to also kind of
like find the patterns and like share
what your fine absolutely yeah yeah you
know what's so beautiful about what you
just said which is just a give you just
being does the third gift clear gift
that you've given me so far probably
plenty others but just clear was around
knowing the nature of the psyche yeah
you know it came to mind for me is I'll
know I will be so so connected to so
many people like when I thought like
tens of thousands for me what came to
mind is all have touched the hearts yeah
and they'll have touched mine of tens of
thousands yes and the value of that for
me as someone who values these deeply
connected on soul realm type
relationships that's just like it's just
I just think of like just like gold
coins you know just like it's so
valuable to have those interconnections
with people but what you said was so
beautiful in it it truly takes it into
when we're thinking of like shamanism
knowing realms of the soul in a
Realms etc etc is that's really this
world that I'm dealing in it's just not
of an individual but this kind of sub
realm where we get to go to and be in it
and then while I'm in it and they're in
it but while I'm in it I get to study
and I get to explore and I get to know
what's in this realm and take notes
which I do on what's going on here
what's the nature of reality here in
this realm that might be different from
this realm how does it connect how does
this connect with this how do I use
words to explain the people how this
world connects to this world in bridged
them oh man and I really feel like so
much of me lives on on that realm so
when I'm in session with somebody in a
psychotherapy session I'm home yeah you
know we talk about modernity and being
disconnected but when I'm there I'm
fully alive they can bring in trauma and
let's be like we get to be in that but
from this other place and so for me it's
so like I walk out a session people say
oh my god you just had like five
sessions
you must be so drained and so tired and
I'm like I'm ready to go like I'm
powered up from that experience so oh
this is good yeah this is good yeah good
good yeah Melanie we too have a similar
feeling when we get the opportunity to
dive into the psyches of people not only
that we host on the program but also
when we're just meeting people at events
etc when you feel like you can use the
power of a question to and also the
power of your presence you're so present
that the person can feel loved radiating
from you so they feel genuine interest
when you ask them a question about their
life and then you ask them a question
they open up their get open it you get
another question you there they're like
gosh this person cares and they keep
opening and it's beautiful because then
before you know it you've learned so
much about someone whose parents were in
Vietnam and then they came over here and
were birth here or it's the conflict
that was happening in South Africa the
last couple of decades all of a sudden
like you're just you you're starting to
pick up histories of the world you're
picking up you know somebody you're
showing someone feels like someone else
randomly cares about them and so they're
they're feeling great too because
someone's giving a [ __ ] and they're
asking them questions and so there's
like there's healing that happens from
just good the art of good conversation
the art of good open-heartedness and
question asking and that's kind of like
a like us like a like a streets version
of of psychotherapy or just of just of
art the art of good conversation yes and
so when I when I think of things like
what has been happening the last couple
of decades in the process of healing
some of the hardest things that we've
went through us as especially as the
United States but even around the world
with genocides and wars they're still
going on go still go I will keep going
we'll keep going we got a heal and if we
heal and if we feel more harmony in
towards the direction we can hopefully
cut that lit this transgenerational
trauma that keeps going
what are these main things that comes is
that when you do things like you see
like I'm so curious about this process
for you you seeing that Black Studies
you seeing wanting to help black men and
women in corporate America what is it
what is it like when you're in that
process of seeing all this what's
clicking for you and also how do you go
about the formulation of these key
things that you want to pass along
yeah yeah definitely so I'm gonna go
back to your earlier question about how
I got you know childhood how I got in
here and then connecting to that because
I think there's a there's a there's a
thread there so yeah so it's interesting
just going all the way back so I was
born into this Buddhist community that
would chant in the morning and chant in
the evening a lot of chanting very
positive very like vigorous and very
multicultural even though it was based
out of Japan
it was extremely ethnically diverse and
racially diverse here in America so for
me grew up in a very multicultural
environment and community in that
Buddhist community but then also in the
San Francisco Bay area and then I'm from
a biracial family so mom is Scottish
Canadian from Saskatchewan and they go
back back back and then to Scotland
father African American Chicago Missouri
Mississippi so you get you know a little
bang and then me and my twin sister made
here in in California so just pulling
from a lot of different communities and
traditions in places that feel good for
me and feel normal for me so for me a
lot of my time is spent in very diverse
communities that's like where I feel
probably most at home where there's just
like ethnic diversity and cultural
diversity things of that nature but then
I went to UC Santa Barbara and started
to learn about mention it transatlantic
slave trade and just thought wow there's
this like horror and tragedy that
happened in our past and how do we let
this happen and coming from this
Buddhist community which was about world
peace and promoted it and me being very
inside of that community like I hear
stories about people they say oh we
didn't you know we didn't just go to
church on Sunday we went like
every day like they were deeply in that
we were like that pretty deep in it but
from this Buddhist perspective so things
that inequality and racism you know I
heard about it but you know I guess I
was late to the party I didn't it didn't
click for me until you know I really got
to Santa Barbara and just started like
there's this whole department Black
Studies and they would talk about it and
again and again and again and I was like
damn how did how did we go wrong where
did we as humanity go wrong and let
something like this happen doesn't need
to happen I grew up in a community where
it wasn't happening why was this
happening how did how did nobody stop
this from happening is crazy
and then learning how you know even till
this day there's just inequalities that
still go on and it just made me really
furious inside so you know 18 years old
19 years old prime age psychologically
for the myth of the adults having it all
together breaking down and me realizing
there's so much more randomness and
there's so much more you know hatred in
the world and fear in the world and
greed in the world and and at times it's
just unchecked and just runs rampant
across civilization and I'm like whoa oh
I need to stand up because the people
who are already here ain't got this
thing figured out so I need to find my
place in it and help to find some
solutions and so was at that point when
I really connected with my
african-american lineage and ancestry
and went and talked to my dad I was like
dad what do you know about like
segregation and grandma what do you know
about this stuff and that's when they
started you know they would tell me some
you know some stories here and there and
didn't tell me a whole lot but they did
tell me things and I learned about a lot
of things in history books and I became
an activist and was a co-founder of the
African black coalition and United all
these black student unions in the UC
system and we were successful but
raising millions of dollars for outreach
to you know get more black students onto
the campus to visit and see if they want
to apply cetera et cetera to try and
increase the numbers the numbers were
like two point seven percent so compared
to California State average it was just
low or the national average of what we
have thirteen percent black in America
fourteen percent black people in America
something like that the numbers just
seem like lower they could be higher is
what we were thinking and that was our
effort towards fixing that but even when
I was so you know even when I was very
successful with that I would felt I felt
shitty inside so there's this dichotomy
of outward success in internal turmoil
still so I left all that behind I left
all the activism behind and that's when
I went on this kind of like spiritual
journey inward I was like okay that was
important glad I did it informed me kind
of like rings of a tree boom there's a
ring and now I'm growing cut down a tree
you see all the rings it could tell you
like they say like temperature or was it
a flood that year or a fire that you can
read what happened there you know so
that was a ring and then I continued to
grow like my next ring and I took this
journey and you know just found that
there's this whole inner world which was
also but not also bit differently
connected to this history and lineage
outside and there's so much freedom
inside and for me I found a lot of
healing inside I mean there's things
that you know growing up which were
really hard for me to relate to in my
own family and I just didn't have the
tools or the insights or skill set I
guess it was on how to look at them and
how to orient to them and very much
looked at them as things that had
happened to me that had impacted me
verse a narrative of damn I'm dope I got
through this like I'm here now like I'm
the one who maneuvered that and managed
that and thought my way through that
and got to this point here and now and
my perspective wasn't that and so I
needed the skillset to even shift how I
looked at it which also kind of impacts
you know how I can look at the world
today that yes transatlantic slave
trades like horrible and decimating the
black community still in many ways and
the crack epidemic and things of that
nature but you know there's a lot of
black people who are those that made it
through that like that's massive to come
through slavery to come through the
crack epidemic to continue to shine and
you know and build and not give up and
persevere and yes it's a lot of
amazingness in that but that's about the
you know like the black narrative so
there was that piece for me there's the
personal healing piece for me there's
the psychotherapy piece which is not
black right coming out of the more of a
Jewish community and out of the Jewish
community coming into the larger white
community in Western Europe and then
from there to America and then you know
insurance plans stop paying as much and
then a lot of people kind of leave it a
little bit but now it's creeping into
corporate America Starbucks is just
thrown a ton of money toward mental
health it's starting to be a big thing
because it's a stigma in corporate
America and now mental health is
changing in the black community as well
kanye west talking about bipolar jay-z
and Beyonce talking about couples
counseling you
Charlamagne tha God huge on anxiety you
know so now we have this mashup of the
corporate space and you have this black
community space in mental health is
getting D stigmatized for both and for
me someone who walks between worlds the
black world the white world and also
squarely Center in the mixed world on
this bridge between this knowledge in
this community in providing this
experience I guess for both yeah they
both need each other to succeed yes yeah
do you I do yeah data download data duh
there's so many things here so one of
them that you mention is that we have
this
[Music]
drama continuing to happen across
different places in the world where out
of out of that trauma somehow creates
these greatest treasures in people's
lives and they persevere they're
resilient they somehow manage to get
through and try and teach and help
others to get through that type of stuff
see it as these greatest gifts other
people just transgenerational II have
serious issues with their with money
that I'm with with health relationships
out of wedlock childbirth yeah all
different types of things nom and you
know it's really important to make
distinctions here that that in the sense
of like there are people from around the
world that are of you know you can find
people from the area of like Hugo's
former Yugoslavia then have that I've
had serious since the wars from from a
couple decades ago that have had serious
issues with the same not the same but
similar traumas that people that have
faced other warlike scenarios before too
or other traumas as well and so um we're
talking about this one in the US but
there's so many of them that are around
the world mm-hm then you give this
really good distinction also where you
talk about how corporate America has a
problem that many other places in the
world don't have which is that we have
had our economy built up really again I
don't know how how these numbers
actually are but apparently out of
approximately a I believe the number was
about a about a six hundred million
dollar United States economy during the
times of of a pre thirteenth amendment
that that about 50% of that economy was
due to slavery in the cotton industry
I'm not sure about that statistic but
it's a very interesting one to propose
because the truth is what real
percentage of the economic flourishing
during those times was catalyzed by
something like that leading up to all
the way up to 13th amendment Jim Crow
then the Civil Rights Act etc that all
of a sudden now we have we have a very a
corporate America that's filled with men
now women women in corporate America
which is also completely different
versus women being homemakers completely
different vibes women climbing up
hierarchies um women also having mental
stress and health issues or all of a
sudden now you have more of black people
also in corporate America now and now
you have um who knows me but there'll be
a resurgence of a Native Americans in
corporate America as well in the future
who knows mexican-americans in corporate
America line Americans etc so in the
sense how everyone is being affected by
these similar economic pressures that
our people feel like they're like
they're circular and they're being
pushed through a square peg holes and
they can't fit because we're trying to
gingerbread stamp cookies out into a
machinery store where people have some
sort of a deeper Drive like really who
are you what is your passion who are you
what is inner passion your passion your
passion yeah because if you're not in
the right fit then you're gonna have
mental health problems exactly and
that's what that's where where if a if a
Kanye or beyoncé or jay-z or any of
these other leaders that are stepping up
to talk about this if they're willing to
also be not only take things like the
transgenerational issues that have had
been
opening plus they're able to take the
complexities of today's mental health
internet economy plus the North Stars
not being actualized inner artists not
being actualized by the machinery as
well if they if we can really calculate
in this like hodgepodge of variables and
try and be completely transparent about
the weight of all of these variables how
to architect that social fabric that is
actually more prosperous really I feel
like so much of it comes from grassroots
just one on one dives into the psyche
and healing like this that if you
catalyze tens of thousands of people
healing over your lifetime you're doing
like insanely good for our society and I
think a lot of it comes from this
one-on-one healing and especially if
someone like a like a Kanye or or jay-z
or Beyonce get a profound healing then
that can be massively catalytic I mean
you just see it right now with Kanye see
right now with the way that he's
speaking about things that transcend him
making music that's trying to transcend
him to try and inspire other people to
also find themselves and be themselves
in the world so all of these things
mixing together to what I think is now
becoming one of the greatest healing
swings that a society has ever made in
it Wow okay wow that's great news does
it feel like it's a like it's really it
feels like you are part of this massive
swing where who would have thought that
you would have taken up a role as a
psychotherapist specifically for black
men and women in corporate America that
are having that that that you want to
have positive a day-to-day moment to
moment psyche all psychological and and
well-being in general yeah you know I
don't I mean I mean it's a beautiful
thing love it and I don't think it's so
far-fetched my father's a very severe
oh man and was is deeply involved in the
black community so that's kind of what I
was a part of as a child not just in the
Buddhist community but you know he just
more science and different black
community like forms of spirituality
that I was exposed to so and I've always
been spiritual as well and he was a
businessman when he was working and so
for me it's not too far-fetched that I'm
doing what I'm doing now and I always
even from a young age like asked me when
I was a kid like what do you want to do
and you know superheroes I want to you
know I want to save the world like when
I get older so for me it was I think all
is always a question of like how do I
want to make positive impact and I've
done things throughout my life which
have been like give back type activities
and so this stage of my life now it's
just been more about how do i you know
enable myself to do that in you know a
structure where you got to pay bills and
got to eat and got it you know put gas
in the car and and make all that work on
the adulting function inside of things
as well so for me it feels I mean it
feels like a really it feels like a
great fit but I'll also name that jewel
love as a being and as a brand is I work
with the black community but I don't
just work with the black community
that's that's one of my offerings that's
one of my gifts and connection points
but I'm actually connected globally like
who I am actually connects I can connect
with people all over the world part
partly because of how I look I can fit
into so many different play are you
mexican are you black and are you this
are you that like you know that whole
Mediterranean reason I got that unlock
the whole Arab thing I got that a lot
the whole you know Puerto Rico you name
it like check check check when I am mix
with black and white and so it's like it
connects me like Europe in this ways and
Africa in this ways but even beyond all
that man I mean on some level that's
that's cool and that's nice and it's
helpful and fun at times but I think
just the soul and the spirit that I have
and that there other people have it who
are like these global
citizens and see themselves connected to
people all around the world and that's
how I see myself and that's where I see
myself going and corporate America is
it's a great space to connect with
people while all over America that are
truly moving and shaking I mean they're
in centers of power that are
unbelievable and have connections to
resources these these are come you know
these are companies with forty thousand
a hundred thousand people with like
billions and billions of dollars it like
coming into them bitching they're
massive in in scope and in profit and in
reach and in development so to actually
get a foothold in these worlds it's
almost like in governments you know
around the world and for us Silicon
Valley I mean to be born in anywhere
else it's just this is the center of so
much that we're a part of right here so
to have you know to be able to tap that
pulse and then to be able to whisper in
someone's ear who has a significant
amount of power and then to speak to
significantly large audiences and start
to help to move and craft
yes profits but yes the earth yes
humanity and how do we move forward in a
way which you know you know stockholders
are happy with but that also deeply take
into account what's going on with the
world today in our relationship with it
I feel a sweet spot there and healing
yeah totally could see it being a huge
part of that
but that's also the growing edge for for
me moving forward so deeply definitely
connected to the black community and
like a lot of soul connection there and
there's something connected to society
in the world as a whole which I'm
interested in in giving those gifts to
what did you end up synthesizing was a
part of like the Buddhist path and part
of what you were learning from your
mentor
Eugene Porter as well how did you find
these these in the inner peace process
you're helping people with yeah so the
Buddhist community I was a part of
growing up they had this concept about
human revolution turning poison into
medicine which you can you know you know
difficulties into a life of meaning so
for me that was always the case even
through the ups and the downs and the
feeling disconnected in junior high
school and on top of the world in high
school and then disconnected in college
and then finding connection later on
like through all of that I knew my life
was leading somewhere so I never lost
track of that even when times got
difficult and that's what always kept me
afloat like okay this is tough but I
know it's a purpose in this and I just
need to struggle through and figure it
out so that philosophy that my life
actually has great meaning and I'm here
destined to give a big gift to the world
or multiple gifts to the world has
always kept me on course no matter where
I've been or what's happened or no
matter confusion or clear it's always
been there for me psychotherapy was a
way to do it
this was the philosophy but this for me
other people they got their own ways
gotcha me psychotherapy was just a
massive catalyst to take all of that
stuff and then actually make meaning out
of it and a clear understanding of who I
am who uniquely I am and how I relate to
the world around me and put things in
order for me gave me just a lot more
clarity to turn that you know turn
struggles if you will or questions into
clarity not just for myself though but
how I relate to the world around me and
then to create gifts and offerings to
the world around me and yeah so
psychotherapy was huge in that for me so
I think that's how they both came
together for me and then let's let's
unpack the inner peace process yeah okay
I love this emotional mastery first yes
yes so alright so many of my clients
come in
Harvard grad Yale grad super-smart sharp
love these guys and an education they
never got oftentimes is around emotional
literacy just simple stuff go back to
third grade you know there's a picture
of the happy face and little picture the
sad face and the angry face but we go to
collegiate levels you know hundreds of
different feelings emotions for them to
begin to identify all this rich terrain
that's inside of himself it's kind of
like painting the picture with like
three crayons very simple you know
versus just like masterful like
watercolor you know it's like creations
that are just like oh this is just like
brilliant kind of a thing
so I will rich to you how in what
resolution do you see the textures of
emotions in life in in a couple pixels
crayons or the rich watercolors yeah
like there you go yeah I def watter
colors exact Retina display harder
exactly and there's tools that help
people do that just like having the
retina
you know this tool that can display
what's there was such clarity so you
know just basic sit there with a sheet
of feelings shout-out to nonviolent
communication Marshall Rosenberg
preciate you his Center came out with
the sheet you know front slice posited
and back it's kind of like negative and
I'll have a client just sit there with
the sheet and you know talk about their
boss and say well it wouldn't happen
like how did that make you feel and say
you know just upset like grab the sheet
and grab it and they're just like you
know just like upset remorseful like
embarrassed ashamed like curious
despondent just like this all of this
rain just come and I'm just writing them
all down just like you know providing
that validation just for many of them it
could be as men and could be as black
man but people like very few people have
the experience of having their internal
reality truly validated that's right by
another person so I'm like wait wait
wait this is important this is important
what's that one again a shame
keep going all of them help all of them
down we're gonna write them all down my
stop after ten is there anymore look
over the lid lo and behold guess what
we're going for another 15 you know
feeling getting them all down and then
from there I say well what was that like
for you ya know like damn I didn't even
know I felt that way I'm like exactly
yes exactly
doesn't mean it wasn't there it was
there it impacts you it affects you but
this helps you do clarity with it so
it's improving their relationship with
himself improving their relationship
with himself from there I get the
intensity number one through 10 sad
might be a 1 anger might be 2 10 clears
that up yeah and then I get them to
write down their thoughts about each one
of those
so kind of like a lot of CBT structure
cognitive behavioral therapy type
structure in that process alone just
gives them so much clarity on how they
relate to the stimulus going on outside
of them and that alone clarity on that
just enables them to just have a sigh of
relief around it so that's step one step
two is healthy mindset shifts I'll keep
the second two brief third is optimal
performance healthy mindset shift is
looking at any outdated outmoded and
effective mindset shifts they picked up
from the past then identifying and
adopting healthier mindset shifts that
can move them toward their goal I can't
be often my authentic self it worked -
yeah I can be my on - authentic self at
work and then once we have those
thoughts we go into optimal performance
which are just small measurable goals
that they can do between sessions really
in alignment with those healthy mindset
shifts that if they do them could get
them closer to affirming that healthy
mindset shift and usually that leads to
more positive feelings and emotions and
alignment and they may have
to leave that job in order to get a real
job not a real job but a job that really
supports them or entrepreneurial pursuit
that aligns with the gift that they have
to give inside etc etc so those are
really the three steps really around
emotional mastery really is what it is
yeah and it's been now I think several
times in the last even couple months
I've heard the Lama talking about
emotional hygiene being such an
important thing we talk about physical
hygiene smelling good cleaning
yourselves up I'm going to talk about
emotional hygiene enough and so to see
to hear about this it sounds very good
to specifically be focusing on black men
in the psychotherapy and at large also
women are just having this sort of
emotional hygienic process where we're
identifying what is these complex
emotions with higher resolution and then
that we're able to in a sense have a
healthier mindset around our
decision-making we're absolutely
absolutely uh yeah like this is this is
like why aren't we all in flight for
four-year-old five-year-old six-year-old
seven-year-old just like started to
really dive we could be masters by 18
and social emotional intelligence brains
are incredible and the neuroplasticity
of youth is incredible but we choose to
to is part of the big challenge in
creation that we have these these skill
sets we only develop in our in our 20s
or 30s or sometimes never at all instead
of in the younger days so in the
kindergarten and preschool days instead
of grade school so we need to be doing a
younger and younger especially given
that eacute is gonna be one of the last
areas that a I can try and like this
Software's goes exactly
not a trip yes a trip because everything
that you're doing with psychotherapy is
allowing people to become more and more
socially emotionally spiritually whole
which then makes them less replaceable
by AI there you go absolutely I mean
there's people that are coming in and
teaching that to youth now you know
there's different programs and it Endon
on the AI thing you know there's already
you know they're coming from my job
already it's far even therapists you
know show host yeah so uh hanging on as
long as companies have already been
hitting me up like VR companies and
saying we want to create a program to do
therapy and BR we don't actually need
the therapist we're just gonna create
these programs that people can step into
and so you know an apps are just taken
off left and right so yeah trying to get
on the tech angle my friend yes good
it's actually good maybe you have your
maybe you do Joe join in on the VR or
the voice voice is another one boy yeah
like Alexa or Google assassin oh yeah
yeah yeah play the jewel of three steps
to inner peace yeah bro can we use my
voice yeah see your call yeah yeah see
getting on that is yeah is it makes us
less you have replaceable to um you were
teaching me about this through one of
your videos I thought it was we don't
talk about this enough either the stigma
that's associated with these processes
of becoming more vulnerable more
socially emotionally aware and
intelligent there's the stigmas that I'm
less of a man if I cry I mean that's
like the most I guess classic yeah I'm
one but there's many more you had to
walk us through these stigmas and how to
transcend them and get to our focus yeah
so I think those are so I guess we could
just stick with men then for now is yeah
sure so the socialization of don't be a
[ __ ] don't you know do is are told you
know you're gay these are all the class
that I was not is not positive but what
I heard when I was growing up and
probably said as well I'm sure
so those being two don't be you know
don't don't be weak or it's a [ __ ] or
acting like that she's like anything
that aligned with with femininity was
femininity weakness or sadness or if it
just wasn't tough it was kind of
relegated to something that was viewed
as less than or weaker than or in the
realm of feminine and I think that's
just such a toxicity and I'm not a fan
of using toxic masculinity and I
actually just to clarify really quickly
and then to circle back talk about like
toxic masculinity healthy masculinity
toxic manhood like healthy manhood and
thinking about masculinity really just
being as assertiveness and femininity
being about receptivity and so that's
not necessarily male nor female when we
talk about toxic masculinity anybody can
be used their assertiveness in a way
that's harmful to themselves or to
others anybody same thing with passivity
can be used in ways that harms one's
self or others and then there's things
like manhood which is I view of like and
this kind of relates to black executive
men but also urban healers which is
having a certain level of achievement in
realms of Finance relationships I'd say
mental and emotional health when it when
and where possible because some mental
health disorders are just not solvable
right now
career possibly a sense of purpose and
achieving those states and oftentimes
when men don't achieve those states by a
certain age they don't seem to be
particularly happy or satisfied so what
comes to mind is what are the societal
structures in place that allow men to
achieve proficiency or excellency our
mastery in those realms as an adult male
and then what are some systems that
either challenge men to achieve
State or prohibit them altogether and
when we then circle all the way back
around to this thing around emotions I
think that's one place that's it's
getting looked at now in our society of
what are some structures and systems
that can help men actually mature into
that place where if they want they can
tap into this rich emotional tapestry
which can allow them to form deep and
meaningful relationships which is
important for human beings to thrive and
survive I believe in many studies have
shown so I think that's just the shift
that I see happening now especially post
me to era cannot leave that out and it
just is and and been important in this
shift that's been happening for a bit I
think it's definitely catalyzed it so
what I've done is I look at at the same
time well that's all happening I keep in
mind you know as a man and grew up in
the Bay Area and those stereotypes in
the Staten third this thing around alpha
energy and it's very important so now
we're kind of like in the men's work
world and kind of leaning in that
direction where there's a lot of talk
about like alpha energy and beta energy
like pickup world and in men's
psychology type world and maybe even
some sports psychology type world where
that concept it still played out in a
very big way and definitely probably
like gang type world as well
alpha alpha male Alpha energy leadership
energy the military same as well
hierarchy jordan peterson talks about
that very much as well so how do we
capture that it's not going anywhere for
men you put a hundred men in the room
you're gonna figure out the Alpha by the
end of seven days like it's just gonna
sort itself out it just blew them and
then you have a leader or a leadership
kind of a thing and it may change over
time but there it is so how do we not
try and get rid of that there's often a
philosophy of like out with that and
then squash the hierarchy and just
everything equal across the board and
I'm not really for that I think how is
it that we aren't
this alpha energy that happens in groups
but also exists I think within men and
then just going back to this this de
masculinity like assertiveness how do we
you know capture that and honor that
don't take that away from a man that can
be his safety that can be his in-group
identity safety and if you take that
away and strip him of that and don't
give him anywhere to go
it's like annihilation like
psychologically it's like a death threat
and you know for him to lose status to
that degree it's just not a tenable you
know result or thing to tell a man to do
so I you know what I'm not so much for
that but what comes to mind for me is
how do you create an identity brand and
harness this alpha energy for a
pro-social outcome so an example of
these things are like sports teams not
the pro-social necessarily but a sports
team people you know I used to wear Joe
Montana Jersey another man and when I
wore his jersey I was the man why cuz
everybody likes Montana he's an approved
male in males many of us not all but
many walk around from sunup to sundown
trying to get our man card check how we
do our here the clothes we wear the
words we say the way we position our
bodies as we move around town you know
the postures the lingo the things that
we watch it's all like okay you're a man
okay you're a man okay you're a man wear
that Jersey you're a Superman you're a
hero man you're you stamp stamp stamp
stamp stamp so I keep that in mind
hence black executive men it says
nothing about psychotherapy at all but
it's a powerful brand and it's the
aspiration of my clients that's what
they want to be and see themself as to
some degree already yes I work with a
lot of middle managers not necessarily
actually incorporated like the head of
the Google right more like middle
manager types that want to be up there
or start their own company yeah so
that's what I used to project to the
world and they
powerful associating himself with that
brand and they can wear a jersey that
says black executive man they can have a
little pin that says B e em they can
have a hoodie on and do wear them that
say B e em it's a powerful thing it
affirms their manhood and masculinity
and alpha energy yeah but on the inside
when they're sitting with me in a room
what are we doing we're doing classic
psychotherapy we're doing the same thing
that most other people are doing
emotional literacy tears processing
trauma etc etc so I think in this
movement to cultivate emotional hygiene
there is the approach of just saying it
flat out
emotional literacy is important open up
talk about how you feel you can even get
fierce it's important open up you got to
show how you feel this is it this is the
right way do it this way then uh this is
the one this is the one this is the one
go go go
but even in that there's assertiveness
I'm using I'm still harnessing that
energy and then there's a little more
subtle form which is brand formation
that secures men and a male identity
that's still lauded by society but
secretly not even necessarily secretly
but the content of it is around
emotional literacy not the only thing
emotional energy but a big part of it
being emotional literacy and so that's
where my mind I likes to occupy as far
as the marketplace how do you sell the
sizzle not the steak how do you sell
what people want give them what they
need and especially for male identity
brands and I love doing stuff like that
this in so many ways takes me through a
process of seeing myself in the shoes of
people that come and talk to you because
all of us can feel like we have some
sort of growth that we want to embark on
some sort of ways that we want our
consciousness to evolve but it's not
something that we can approach our mom
or our dad about it's not something that
is easy to talk to me be even a best
friend about it's not something easy to
talk to like a romantic intimate partner
about and that's why partly this whole
like psychotherapy shamanic resurgence
is happening around the world people
want to be registered they want to be
felt hurts seen they want to ascend with
someone else in a way that can help them
further not only evolve to become a
better person but also to evolve where
they're at in the world and to hopefully
bring their gifts even more fully into
the world absolutely and as often as we
see a food restaurant across the corners
of our modernity why don't we also see a
little like social emotional wellness
around that many on the corner of so
many different places of modernity we
don't social emotional intelligence have
taken a sweep under the rug while you
can pump yourself full of alcohol or
food sugar salt fat whatever you want
and pretty much at your convenience
so every little like strip mall or
shopping mall area having some sort of a
social emotional component to it would
be great and to democratize that through
VR through voice or through any of the
other tech platforms that we have now
this is different it's a different eye
to eye is much much different than
through the VR is becoming
indistinguishable at cetera we have
artificial intelligences that can do you
know trillions of permutations of your
psychometric state and based on some big
data input that they have about people
like you and so it's just harder for a
human to have that same synthesis of
trillions of your mutation zazz nai
anyway relevant relevant relevant all of
all of those things together like it's
really at the end of the day it's about
ascension it's about evolution it's
about growth it's about healing it's
about collective prosperity that's what
it it comes down to and so for me to
hear you're both your strategies as well
as how to overcome stigma as well as how
to make it so that that someone that has
something deep within them that they
want to open about to he to heal first
with safe energy I mean nothing really
is I think more important than that
maybe one of the most paramount things
is being there for other people for
their evolution in their growth and
knowing how to be there for that and
also you yourself knowing how to evolve
and grow with other people I love that
yeah yeah I mean I think that's a
beautiful framework even is it you know
even teaching it's like how to how to
teach people how to do that how to teach
people a large number of people of how
to be with other people as they go
through their evolutionary process and I
don't know how formally it needs to be
put but just having that skillset and
that insight that that's what's going on
yeah with so many of us I think would be
a valuable tool and skill set and needed
as we come into these very changing very
changing times that are that are upon us
yeah yeah I agree there's a there's a
couple other thoughts that I think we
should that I think we should talk about
on the way out okay
yeah employee resource groups this was
very interesting you're teaching me
about how there's in the little pockets
of the
and we don't even know that they exist
and so then they trying to share with
other people exist so they can leverage
those resources for healing for growth
for evolution yeah yeah so just noting
that you know there's just Mary there's
all kind of different black communities
that that exists so I think in the black
community there's just like probably
many communities there's different
flavors depending on where that that
that group racial or ethnic group is in
the country or in the world or the
religion that they kind of practice but
in the black community there's there's
quite a there's still you know a lot of
similarity but then there's also
definitely some variations
you know there's black Muslims there's
black Christians and Christian certain
Christians out and denominations and the
Buddhists like the ones that I grew up
with some of the community was black
there's wealthy black people and like
really poor and then I get our hood you
know black people or like black people
in the hills or there's the the
fraternities and sororities and and then
there's this whole corporate black
America community which I I knew not I
knew nothing about he like as I think
about it my uncle was african-american
he worked 18 t something like that he
was involved in corporate America to a
degree but now I'm I'm in it I'm in it
much more now and they have these black
communities that exist there from a few
hundred to a few you know thousand
people that are at it at a company for
however long Microsoft they have a black
community there that's over 40 years old
maybe over 50 maybe over 50 years old
maybe over 60 I mean wall of the
segregation and 6260 yeah probably 50
years old something like that oh yeah
and they you know presidents and all
this of this community it's not just a
club it ain't just a club it's a
community in in they support each other
they have Eve
Vence there and it's connected and
inside just like you imagine you know
you have like vel black community inside
of America United States of America so
yeah the black community or coke chiller
people and then you have this whole
little niche community inside of
Microsoft this whole they're like tech
company like massive company and they're
there and they have their own unique
culture that's happening inside so for
me coming into this world in the last
couple years I'm just starting to see
that there's ninety percent of Fortune
500 companies have black er G's player
resource groups and many of them don't
know about each other
some of them do some do but they kind of
cluster in their own company which makes
sense but they have all these
communities that exists in there so for
me it's just fascinating to then like
for me it feels like peeking my head
above like water or the clouds almost
and the reason why I put it like that
really is cuz they have so many
resources at their disposal like many of
these people are paid very well for what
they do like hundreds of thousands of
dollars to do their job
stock benefits annual bonuses working
from home like many time it's just um
it's um I think it would amazed a lot of
black people like a lot of working-class
black people that these people exist
because many of us don't even know they
exist the common narrative doesn't show
them often existing that's not something
we see basketball players we see cops we
you know there's Cosby Show Will Smith
like yeah Will Smith you know tonight
nice home Fresh Prince of bel-air but
it's a whole class of people and they're
amazing like they're really the ones I
know and I'm meeting they're really good
people they care about giving back to
the larger black community care about
community service care about healing
it's just it's a new narrative that I
think most people don't even know exists
in the black community that to me it's a
positive one and it's one that should
definitely be celebrated they're
successful they're successful black
people and it's a beautiful narrative
and more black people especially need to
see this about other black people that
we're doing it it's happening and by
seeing it there's this whole thing about
representation matters and when you can
see somebody who's doing what you want
to do in the mind it just makes it
easier for you to do it as well see us
be it see it be it so for me in that
world it's just been it's been
incredible it has been incredibly
affirming and I think it would be for
the larger black community if they saw
this level of success in intelligence
and just just getting it it's amazing
yeah this miring I'm so fascinated when
you talk about the employee resource
groups and just these little pockets of
of in a sense it's like community that
is hyper focused on the specific
ascension of a specific group mm-hm
which is great because sometimes it is
that the most hurt of people in a
specific scenario are the ones that need
the most focus hmm and so for that
ascension for the best sharing practices
and stuff so when you talk about it at
the corporation's when you talk about it
at the level of doing things like
figuring out like why is it that so many
of our part of our prison population is
black why is it that that's so much of
our of our like what is being taught to
children around the different areas what
is being taught at the corporate levels
around the different areas of the US and
around the world really and just
figuring out what are the best practices
I mean it really at the end it's just
try to find
the best patterns for enabling children
to sell self-actualize their unique
gifts into the world and to heal and
integrate transgenerational trauma in
maximize prosperity for all so er Jesus
were very interesting when you were
teaching me about that just add one I
definitely hear you on the like those
that are most hurt having access and
resources and I think that's huge to
provide people that are hurting with
adequate resources I think in the case
of the ERG a lot of times it's really
about there's a few things but one is
kind of really I would say just being
their authentic self in the workplace
like they just want to be able to more
fully be themself in the workplace and
finding that there are some some
barriers culturally and structurally
structurally culturally for them to be
able to to do that and and just kind of
them walking on eggshells about like
wait how much do I bring in but the
workplace says bring your whole self in
but I don't know if this would really be
appropriate here and there's this piece
of and it's not experienced by by all my
all my clients for sure but it's a
constant state of not knowing if
somebody is looking at them in a
disparaging way because they're black or
African or African American and that
level of what can get to not in all
clients but in some at times this level
of paranoia and I don't mean like a
clinical state of paranoia where they
think people aren't like out to get them
or aren't or something but this nagging
wondering if did they not get the raise
because of their skillset or because of
their race did they get the raise
promotion because of their skillset or
because of their race is somebody
treating them poorly because of their
skillset are because of their race and
there's so much movement toward I think
in society that not being an issue but
it's still and you know many cases for
many
people it still is an issue and so you
have these workers who are coming in
trying to do the job like everybody do
the job get the job done and then
managing all of these interactions in
dynamics and not fully being clear still
clear on all of the elements at play and
how much race is or is not a part of
those and I think it's the not knowing
in many in some cases they feel you know
they know or they feel like they know or
they know whether it's unconscious or
not but just them being not fully aware
of how much they're being impacted by
their race in eyes of others yeah yeah
and so that in and of itself can take a
toll which is why main reason why these
er G's exist for them to come together
and like not have to focus on that and
have a reprieve from that type of
experience in their own bodies for for a
while
yes yeah this there's another black
community that you're teaching about the
Gullah Geechee delegate Joey delegation
which I thought was so interesting that
I'm the face still exist gu l lah and
then GE e CH EE which are in the
southeastern part of the United States
which have retained lots of their
African indigenous Heritage's that's
that's a very interesting black
community pockets this thing we talked a
little bit about the importance of
one-on-one mentorship and having yeah
having that like Co be it that type of
stuff that was so important um some of
the things that we typically ask our
guests on the program is like you know
there's a big issue that we're facing
right now with inequality we see the way
that trees larger trees sequester access
carbon and redistribute them across
their tree and fungal networks to
smaller seedlings of smaller trees we
don't really have that same style of
inclusive stake holding in our
hierarchies
and so it's causing a little bit of a
problem where someone's just out and
about buying more and more properties
and making it harder for maybe artists
or entrepreneurs spiritual leaders in
those metropolitan areas to you know
because real estate is a great asset to
diversify your portfolio with and so you
know buying a 15th the sign or bag
instead of actually caring about the
person that's on the street that's your
brother or sister these are very hard
things to analyze what are your thoughts
about inequality and how we can
architect a more prosperous social
fabric yeah that's a great question my
goodness you know there is a yeah so
yeah I guess there's a couple answers
come to mind there's a program called
hidden genius which teaches black boys
how to code and it is that very much
that see it be it type model because in
their advertising and marketing you'll
see pictures of these black boys again
in a game like coding and coding they're
happy and they're coding and they're
traveling and they're coding and they're
going to South Africa and they're coding
and they're going to Raiders game
they're coding and they're coding and
could and after a while just like I just
start to you know like even my cousins
and they're mixed black and white a lot
of mix black and white people in my
family it's pretty it's fairly
predominant somewhat for this yeah
fairly predominant in my generation at
least and and so I think of them I'm
like and I know they're into tech like
heavy and like oh they could you know go
to this hidden gene maybe they're
interested in this hidden genius thing
so even that's this narrative that's
being created that can help track black
boys well into this program and then
they're connect with you know I'm
Silicon Valley and tying them into this
tech community and helping to begin to
fill the pipeline because there's been
this like outcry of like there's not
enough you know black people in tech and
then tech companies are like I see them
out there they're hustling like they're
trying to pick people up I don't know
all that's going on there but I see them
going for it like they have people hired
for these kind of like diversifying
their workplace type of
hols and I think if there was even more
even more I don't know how many there
are but even more and they were
connected to these companies you could
really start that shift of young black
boys seeing themselves as this is an
option this is a pathway toward this
lifestyle and there's the infrastructure
of mentoring etc to get them to go in
that direction now that's a it's a small
thing it's a big thing it's mighty it's
small and mighty it's not you know
taking on thousands and thousands of
people or boys but that's one thing that
to me it speaks of how do how do we
integrate populations that may be
under-resourced or historically
marginalized or just feel like they
can't succeed and give them the mental
pathway in order to obtain the skillset
to succeed in this society in this
economy which is a freaking robust
opportunity pending on what side of the
coin you're on type of economy as far as
kind of like leveling the economy or
like just outright give back
we're just moral evolution to the point
where it's not like a government forcing
function but rather it's an awakening of
people that are deciding to architect
the next generation that's more
prosperous for more people for more
people yeah yeah I think it would just
be mad so I don't really know I've heard
things about the new economy
conversation I'm just very kind of newer
to that there's at times people go to
like conscious capitalism or you have
folks lean more into socialism which
says you know it's they probably might
not exactly but might kind of look at it
that way of like how do we just not
full-on socialism but distribute more of
the the profits of within our society
more equitably things of that nature and
you know from the goodness of their
heart may very well believe that that's
the best way to go about doing it how to
actually get it done in a place like
America I gotta sit with that one I got
to go into my dream space and see what
comes up
for that well that's that's a huge task
yeah and then do you think that we are a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence if I understand what you're
asking me yeah yeah yeah definitely you
know I've been thinking you know I'm not
too much of a conspiracy theorist per se
so that's why this one concerns me
because it feels just next definitely
next I mean technology is just it's
growing so rapidly and are known exactly
how old you are but you know 27 era yeah
27 in our lifetime it's grown so
tremendously fast and growing so fast
and seeming like it she's gonna keep
going faster and faster yeah
did they talk about it just being able
to do things much more efficiently than
then we can and I can totally see that
like I was driving over here I was like
you know you know bones and like yoga
loved going to yoga two three times a
week great experience and then sometimes
you know I just feel like you know bones
or fingers or some things could get kind
of stiff and I'm like damn if I have
like titanium like bones like muscle not
muscles with like fingers and things
like that it's just like Terminator type
you know it's like I could just be
Bionic man ya know so I think even the
lore of human not all but me in some
ways and probably others is like I could
process faster I could keep up I could
get an advantage oh yeah if I had this
stuff like what is a head of Tesla Elon
Musk sees like we got an output problem
you know we got two thumbs neural lace
yeah yeah stuff like that so you know I
know it draws and shouldn't draw quite a
bit of criticism for all kind of reasons
but I think the demand is actually there
in the human population for that kind of
fan sment and there's just you know it's
interesting it seems like Tex just kind
of will have a mind and a life of its
own that could definitely will
definitely outpace our abilities and
it's the trick cuz I was listening to
Sam Harris over here as well and he's
like our reaction is not as as big as it
should be to the threat of you know some
possible annihilation and I think it's
true there's even like a intrigue with
it which is really curious thing to sit
with which I haven't done a whole lot of
yet yeah but uh I'm actually I think so
yeah yeah in it's mind-boggling yeah do
you think we have free will
yes within the confines of within
certain confines yeah yeah the confines
of society values that are around us
free will yes do we exercise and fully I
don't even think we're even fully aware
of all the options yeah that we
necessarily have but yeah free will yes
I think we do have it more degrees of
freedom for more people the more
spiritually awake you are the more
you're able to pick your with your free
will rather than be manipulated yeah
yeah yeah exactly what do you think is
most beautiful flowers the House passes
definitely flowers yeah yeah the peony
love flowers and i you know ii comes up
for me as leaves leaves many times would
have fallen on the ground already like
fall time and just all the colors for me
it speaks to it speaks to humanity about
every leaf is just slightly a little bit
different and but just so just so
beautiful and I'm just amazed by some of
the leaves I see on the ground no bright
yellow and like really like like burnt
like orange like ready
leaves and it's something that it moves
me inside yeah just the variety and the
vibrancy of these leaves and that
they're on the ground there's something
interestingly about that like discarded
like no one cares or they're done but
they're so beautiful there yeah that
juxtaposition so beautiful like they are
it's very cyclical cycle of life II
mm-hmm yeah yeah in that phase of it yes
he's of it so beautiful but all the way
out yeah yeah yep yeah yeah I like that
answer a lot yeah yeah I forgot uh which
might have been a Ralph Waldo Emerson or
something like that that said that uh
the earth laughs and flowers mmm I like
that yeah I love now I do good I mean I
like just the earth laughing just eat
yeah that concept
yeah but thin and flowers is just as
just like this beautiful you know
pinion waves or anything and that been
yeah I've been dope went to would like
flowers I like that one
there's also secretes all of the
consciousness awakening plant medicines
that we need to awaken that's true it
secretes that them and we consume them
awaken and then realize who we really
are
yeah such a gift
Wow yeah I love that yeah thanks to the
earth right now I love it
yeah these breaths of air coming from
her we're so deeply interconnected with
it absolutely yeah yeah yeah Julis has
been epic yeah that's right so funky
thank you
thanks for coming on the program
absolutely thank you for having us yeah
a nice deep dive yeah super-good deep
dive thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking we would love for you to have
more conversations with your friends
families co-workers people online about
Corporate America but all these topics
that jewel is teaching us on the program
today have more conversations about
those check out the links in the bio
below again black executive men calm the
urban healers calm also check out Jules
content on his YouTube page linked in
Instagram check those out as well and
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders the organizers and
around the world that you believe in in
your community support them help them
grow you can find our links below to our
show so we can get seen doing cool
things like traveling around
interviewing great minds etc PayPal
patreon cryptocurrency all those links
are below and gonna build the future
everyone architect that more prosperous
social fabric that our hearts you know
as possible you love you very much we'll
see you soon